[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce rallye doit retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du sky échos le
récit des aventures économique du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
au programme aujourd'hui nous allons
parler notamment d'un opticien installé
à mort par wissam jallow a créé son
entreprise d'optique à domicile nous
l'avons suivi lors d'une livraison
reprise du dynamisme sur le marché de
l'immobilier d'entreprise à saint
quentin en yvelines cent soixante douze
mille mètres carrés ont été transactés
en 2021 enfin c'est une start up
innovantes pour les chaînes
d'approvisionnement des entreprises ce
qui nous avions se propose une solution
de prévision des ventes et je disais
dans les titres le marché l'immobilier
d'entreprise à saint quentin en yvelines
et dynamique entre les ventes et les
locations de bureaux ou de sites
d'activités les résultats de 2021 sont
en hausse après nos nids et une années
2020 en recul du fait de la crise
sanitaire les transactions au togo
menthe et des emplacements des
implantations mais aussi des nouveaux
projets nous avons fait le point avec
christine turc et de beauregard
directrice attractivité immobilier
d'entreprise à saint quentin en yvelines
bonjour ce signe turc et de beauregard
bonjour nico large alors nous voilà
devant le bâtiment native dernier en
construction emblématique de saint
quentin en yvelines qui vient d'être
livré par le groupe codic alors quelles
sont les caractéristiques de ce projet
alors déjà les caractéristiques de ce
projet c'est que c'est un projet qui est
réalisé par le promoteur codic promoteur
historique qui réalise beaucoup
d'opérations sur le territoire de saint
quentin est là qui vient de livrer
vraiment dans le quartier prime de 51 en
yvelines le dernier immeuble qui fait
dix neuf mille mètres carrés qui est en
r + 8 avec des plateaux de 2000 m² et
surtout on ne le voit pas d'ici mais il
ya énormément de terrasses végétalisées
et un roof top avec une terrasse de 500
m² donc ouverte aux salariés et avec le
dernier étage qui sera disponible pour
des salles de réunion des événements etc
et surtout la particularité de cet
immeuble c'est qu'il est extrêmement vie
très très lumineux et au niveau de
l'agencement avec des matériaux de
qualité des matériaux très sobre et du
coup au niveau de l'aménagement ça sera
vraiment très facile à faire et bien
évidemment il a tous les labels
développement durable qui vont bien
breeam excellente et c est la
particularité c'est que cet immeuble
donc à la base c'était l'immeuble qui
était occupé par la poste qui faisait fi
1500 mètres carrés qui a été racheté par
codic au groupe alliance en 2017 qui a
démoli cet immeuble pour reconstruire
donc cet immeuble emblématique et
surtout la particularité ce qu'il a été
loué à 83% par le groupe orange qui va
regrouper sur cet immeuble quatre
entités qui sont répartis sur le
territoire particularité aussi c'est
qu'il ya des commerces et puis
finalement ce projet c'est le début
aussi d'une reconfiguration de tout le
quartier de la gare avec le
développement de commerce voilà tout à
fait alors sur cet immeuble vous aurez
500 m² de commerces en rez-de-chaussée
mais il y a également tous les espaces
publics de l'hyper centre donc qu'ils
vont être réhabilités par saint quentin
en yvelines et donc tout ce quartier va
être complètement transformé avec bien
évidemment la continuité par codic du
projet halo rouge donc démolition de
cette de cet immeuble qui donne vraiment
une très mauvaise impression lorsqu'on
arrive sur saint quentin en yvelines par
les transports en commun qui va être
démoli et codic la reconstruire trois
immeubles pour une surface totale de 2
20 mille mètres carrés avec des
rez-de-chaussée en pied d'immeuble avec
de la restauration des bars pour
vraiment animé tout ce quartier et à
voir surtout une transparence à partir
du maïs des sols jusqu'à la gare qui est
plutôt une gare plutôt confidentielle à
l'heure actuelle et qui sera vraiment
ouverte on va faire un bilan maintenant
de l'année 2020 en termes d'immobilier
d'entreprise une bonne année je crois
savoir que 2021 ça a été une bonne année
effet de rattrapage ou par rapport aux
collines ou est ce que c'est une
véritable dynamique non alors c'est une
véritable dynamique c'est vraiment une
très très bonne année par rapport déjà à
2020 mais bon ça c'était la période kovy
de confinement et cetera mais c'est une
bien meilleure année également que 2019
et une très bonne année par rapport aux
cinq dernières années la particularité
donc c'est con à 178 mètres carrés à la
fois à la location à l'acquisition
interpierre purement locaux d'activité
entrepôts avec la particularité de cette
année vraiment on est à peu près
équivalent en mètres carrés transactés
et en nombre de transactions donc on a
par exemple une des plus grandes
transactions ces ora nos qui s'est
transférée dans les locaux du futur à 2
sur 8 mille mètres carrés on a le cnas
qui a déménagé du parc ariane pour
s'installer et il a acquis en fait le
l'immeuble energia est en fait ce qu'il
ya d'intéressant sur 50 ans et que on
permet aux entreprises de déménager dans
des locaux aux dernières normes
environnementales qui répondent vraiment
aux demandes de des salariés aux
nouvelles modes d'organisation du
travail au télétravail bien évidemment
puisque on réduit les surfaces mais il
faut faire revenir les gens au bureau et
donc grâce à toutes ces opérations comme
celle de codic mais pas que on a
également cfc développement qui est en
cours de livrer le proxima 6 sur le pas
du lac on a également un tout petit peu
plus loin sur l'avenue la venue du
centre on a tout le quartier des cadrans
qui a été refait par baissé et on a le
bâtiment le follow qui doit être livrée
qui fait 6000 mètres carrés une dernière
question quels sont les projets futurs
sur n'ont pas cette année puisque vous
avez parlé de native et aussi de faux
lomé sur les prochaines années 2023 2024
et peut-être 2025 même tout à fait alors
justement on a on a établi un l'année
dernière un schéma directeur
d'implantation économique nous avons
repris l'ensemble des zones d'activité
de 50 ans donc environ une trentaine
qu'on a qualifié et surtout on les a
identifiés classifiés et grâce à cela
nous pouvons travailler justement sur
des nouveaux projets avec des opérateurs
donc on a la zone du pas du lac qui est
en pleine reconversion également avec un
projet de pas que d'activités r&d mais
on a également tout le pôle ski
high-tech qui est une nouvelle entrée
sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin et de
paris saclay jeu justement pour préciser
ce qu'est ce qui lie tex et plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois et la sortie
d'elancourt en direction de plaisir tout
à fait alors là c'est un c'est un projet
très innovant puisque nous avons
regroupé quatre maires et nous avons
travaillé sur cinq zones d'activités
donc les deux zones d'activités de
plaisir santa pauline gâtine la clé
saint-pierre à elancourt pis alloue à
trappes et puis jaloux aux
clayes-sous-bois et donc on a fait tout
un travail d'étude mais très complet
aussi bien en développement économique
en aménagement qu'en développement
durable etc donc on a fini ce travail
d'étude maintenant on commence à
travailler de façon opérationnelle et on
travaille sur plusieurs projets donc
avec spirit avec poudre ide avec sa ré
as avec six gros et dont toute cette
zone va être complètement transformé on
va amener également de la mobilité les
aménagements vont être également refaits
par rapport aux desserts à
l'accessibilité donc c'est vraiment un
grand projet d'envergure et c'est
surtout la future zone
industrielle 2.0 qui s'ouvre sur le
plateau de saclay qui serait une
nouvelle entrée sur la région ile de
france eh bien merci christine turquie
de beauregard merci beaucoup nicolas je
rappelle que vous êtes là la directrice
attractivité et immobilier d'entreprise
pour saint quentin en yvelines
le sky échos se poursuit avec une
rencontre où hassan jallow est opticien
itinérant il commercialise des lunettes
au domicile ou sur le lieu de travail de
ses clients une activité lancée en 1021
depuis maurepas nous l'avons suivi lors
d'une livraison une immersion signé
xavier jaglin
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue chez jal optique je
suis wissam jallow gérant déjà les
optiques opticien à domicile et en
entreprise aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de mon métier mais avant cela je
vous montrer mon atelier pour découvrir
l'univers de l'optique à domicile
suivez-moi
tout d'abord je vous présente ici c'est
une petite mallette pour vérifier là
dessus avant chaque vente on procède à
une vérification visuelle si le client
le souhaite ici nous avons l'échelle des
cultures visuelles
ça me permettra aussi de déchiffrer
l'acuité visuelle due chaque client
c'est la boutique qui se déplacent les
clients il ne fait rien il peut
s'asseoir sur son canapé
entouré par sa famille au derrière son
bureau ventura passant par ses collègues
aient choisi les lunettes en toute
convivialité
la création de jal optique a été réalisé
à fin juin 2021 memory un client c'était
fin août et 2021 aussi nous avons notre
mâle est où il ya le lecteur carte
vitale pour prendre en charge la partie
sécurité sociale et mutuelle ici nous
avons une chaufferette pour régler serré
ou desserrer les lunettes de chaque
personne et si nous avons notre
collection de lunettes
ça fait partie de collections fabriquées
en france et des matières bio sourcés
[Musique]
là on va effectuer du stand livraison
pour un client
[Musique]
on va vérifier si tout va bien s'il voit
bien qu'ils auront tiré en adaptation ça
c'est sûr mais on va surtout contrôler
l'acuité visuelle après
bonjour monsieur vous regarde vous allez
bien oui j'aime bien les goûts lunettes
voir 1
[Musique]
mais
tel système est très ouvert
[Musique]
deux des bons bons côtés je suis ravi
que le service vous à tout un plat c'est
parti
découverte maintenant d'une start-up
skew sayoud propose une solution pour
optimiser et anticiper
l'approvisionnement des produits vendus
par ses clients actuellement en phase
d'accélération elle est accompagnée par
le ski cub et la société wilko c'est la
séquence ma vie d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
suisse stéphane leclerc je dirige la
société students nous sommes installés à
skis tubes à la société a été créée en
2018 par trois associés une somme
éditeurs de logiciels mais nous
proposons une solution qu'une plateforme
saas accessible en ligne pour les
prévisions des ventes
[Musique]
notre solution permet à nos clients de
faire des prévisions automatiquement
mais surtout de l'est de suivre au fait
que la précision de ses prévisions leur
fiabilité pour identifier les produits
en fait qui sont critiques qui sont le
plus important pour l'activité de nos
clients est vraiment se focaliser
vraiment sur ces produits-là
automatiquement nous avons des clients
dans l'industrie manufacturière pour le
monde du commerce également dans le
médical et la santé est également dans
l'agroalimentaire nous avons des clients
notamment au mexique aux états-unis en
australie dans l'agro alimentaire
typiquement un client va vouloir faire
des prévisions à la semaine ou au mois
typiquement la semaine s'il va
gérer son site de production et pour
éviter d'avoir des pertes de matière
donc l'idée c'est de prendre les données
historiques de part de tous les articles
qui ont été vendues sur les trois
dernières années et l'outil
automatiquement va générer en fait pour
les deux prochaines semaines les
meilleures prévisions pour chaque
article
actuellement nous sommes en phase
d'amorçage nous sommes accompagnés par
wilko pour la partie développement
commercial puisqu'en fait il accompagne
les start up et accélère les startups
jusqu'aux premiers millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires wilko nous amène en
fait un mentorat typiquement nous avons
un mentor qui nous est dédié pour nous
accompagner sur la problématique
principale qui est celle de la
l'expansion commerciale également nous
pouvons participer à des ateliers qui
sont spécialisés comme je recommande
comment financer développer la société
pour cette expansion pour financer cette
expansion commerciale le programme
d'accompagnement de wilko en fait de
nous permettre d'atteindre 1 million
d'euros d'ici 2024 ou avant
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission sky ico
merci de l'avoir suivi une émission que
vous pouvez revoir en replay sur notre
site internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur tv soixante dix
huit pour de nouvelles aventures
économique
[Musique]
m